[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we had a very long open
yesterday in fact we spend almost half
of last night's show telling you about
the rise of left-wing mobs in this
country and the threat they pose to all
of us we felt it was that important we
told you that no matter what they're
claiming on television or how loudly
they are claiming it their main goal is
power it always is in order to seize
that power they will do literally
anything whatever it takes
they'll silence you they'll hurt you
they'll burn your country down and
they're doing all of that now you're
watching it so the question is how
should you respond to this and the
answer is with courage you're an
American you live in a free country you
have nothing to be ashamed of you don't
have to apologize for crimes you did not
commit you have the absolute right to
say exactly what you believe is true
that is your birthright now is the time
to affirm that right out loud what
enough decent people rise from their
knees and stand down the mob the mob
evaporates these people are not warriors
they are vampires they melt in the light
when we show them we are not afraid they
go away that's what we told you last
night minutes after we said that the mob
came for us irony of ironies they spent
the last 24 hours trying to force this
show off the air for good they won't
succeed in that thankfully we work for
in the last brave companies in America
and they're not intimidated we're
grateful for that but the whole thing
did get us thinking that we should be
more specific about who this mob is and
what they're doing who are the people
trying to take over your country cancel
your rights eliminate our century's long
tradition of Tolerance yes tolerance and
a free expression and the truth is we
often don't know their names they're
mostly faceless political agitators who
exist primarily online they're trolls
who thrive on cruelty and yet suddenly
they have immense power over all of us
weak leader is now reflexively bow to
their demands no matter what those
demands are why is that what's changed
well that's a much longer conversation
we probably ought to do an entire show
on that topic and if the news ever comes
down long enough to think in bigger
terms
well we we will do that but for now it's
enough to say that the country's
defenses have been badly weakened by
decades of relentless propaganda all of
it designed to make us feel that we have
no right to stand up for ourselves to
stand up for our country we are too
sinful to resist we deserve whatever we
get shut up and take it America we could
spend days showing you examples of this
but here's just the very latest it's
from CNN over the weekend yeah I'm
bringing this sign to the protest at the
community center later they are sad and
upset and they have every right to be
Elmo people are upset because racism is
a huge problem in our country across the
country people of color especially in
the black community are being treated
unfairly because of how they look it's
children's show got that Bobby America
is a very bad place and it's your fault
so no matter what happens no matter what
they do to you when you grow up you have
no right to complain
that's the message and it starts very
young where does it end up exactly we're
finding out here's where it ends up
Alexander khatai is a Serbian soccer
player who until the other day played
professionally for the galaxy in Los
Angeles last week to Ty's wife posted
criticism online of the looters she was
watching rec Minneapolis a lot of people
felt that way cat-eyes wife wrote in
Serbian when she speaks and yet someone
noticed them anyway and then attacked
her for writing them she deleted the
post very quickly but it was too late
now we should be clear that her husband
the soccer player may not even have
known that she wrote the post his wife
was in Chicago when she wrote them he
was practicing with his team in Los
Angeles but it didn't matter protesters
dutifully arrived at the stadium to call
for his firing so the management of the
LA Galaxy forced khatai to apologize for
his wife and then she denounced her
denounce his own wife then they made him
endorse black lives matter which he did
and then they fired him anyway and then
they attacked him on his way out for
something he didn't even do
and may not even have known about that
was written in a language almost nobody
in America understands that's what
happened
the team's president Chris Klein sent it
pleased by the whole thing quote in the
end he said we have to look at what the
club stands for and who we are hmm who
we are it's a good question actually who
are we well at this point we're becoming
North Korea we now believe in blood
guilt we punish people for the sins of
their relatives
we don't allow individuals to have
private thoughts we hurt anyone who
disagrees with orthodoxy we demand that
the innocent plead guilty to things we
know they didn't do and then read their
confessions in public to prove they've
been re-educated and then we brag about
doing all of this obviously something
terrifying has descended on America and
it's easy to see if you stand back what
has happened terrible ideas suddenly
have free reign why because no one
pushes back those ideas are met with
supine weakness you've seen it happen a
thousand times some professional
activist says something crazy and
destructive because that's what
professional activists do always defund
the police what's changed what's
brand-new is that no one in charge has
the stones to disagree
so the rhetoric gets even crazier and
more destructive kill the police okay
what next
UCLA is now investigating a professor
for the crime of reading Martin Luther
King's letter from Birmingham jail out
loud meanwhile also at UCLA another
professor called Gordon Klein is under
police protection tonight
what did Gordon Klein do wrong well when
minority students asked to be exempted
from final exams after George Floyd died
Klein refused he said everyone of all
colors has to take the exam UCLA
immediately suspended him students
threatened to kill him now Klein has
police cars outside of his house all of
this is happening right now in America
the question is is anyone defending
these guys defending the right to give
exams or to read Martin Luther King out
loud
probably not no one's defending anyone
anymore it's every man for himself
meanwhile the worst ideas the ones that
could harm all of us are growing in
power
last week the cosmetics company L'Oreal
announced it was high
a black transgender model called Monroe
Bergdorf Bergdorf will sit on the
company's newly formed diversity and
inclusion Advisory Board Bergdorf had
worked at L'Oreal before if you follow
fashion you know that but got fired
three years ago for reading this
specifically addressed to white people
were going to quote from it quote your
existence privilege and success as a
race is built on the backs blood and
death of people of color your entire
existence is drenched in racism racism
isn't learned it's inherited and
consciously or unconsciously passed down
through privilege once white people
begin to admit that their race is the
most violent and oppressive force of
nature on earth then we can talk
end quote now Monroe Bergdorf got canned
for writing that L'Oreal announced that
crackpot racial theories were contrary
to quote diversity and tolerance toward
all people irrespective of their race
that of course is too true or it was
true it's not true anymore apparently at
least now at L'Oreal L'Oreal has
apologised for ever
supporting tolerance and diversity and
is now rehired bergdorf the idea that
racism can be inherited and passed down
is now consistent with L'Oreal's black
lives matter inspired HR policies some
employees there must be worried we
should all be worried this is terrifying
we should fight against sweeping racial
attacks like this with everything we
have not because we're sympathetic to
the specific group they're going after
but because it is wrong always no matter
what no matter who the target is no
child is born evil
sin cannot be inherited that's insane
certain racial groups are not morally
superior to other racial groups and we
should never condemn any ethnicity as
quote the most violent and oppressive
force of nature on earth that's not see
talk I'm sorry it is it is today the
left is singled out one ethnic group to
hate and punish but tomorrow it will be
another ethnic group bigots never stop
with just one and it will be every bit
as wrong when they do that to other
people as it is wrong now because it's
always wrong
we have an entire monument on the
National Mall in Washington dedicated to
the idea
that in America citizens are judged by
the content of their character not by
the color of their skin
we don't always live up to that ideal
obviously but it's got to be the ideal
if we give up on that if we stop trying
to treat people equally under the law
all people all Americans all citizens
then we're done at that point this
country is simply a collection of angry
tribes and violence is inevitable that's
where we're heading tonight at very high
speed Democrats are thrilled as they
watch it they believe they can win the
November election by inciting tribalism
and division and maybe they can but what
then how do you put the country back
together Republicans have a moral duty
to defend us from this to stand up now
right now when it counts for America's
highest and Moton most important ideals
this right now is the crisis that we all
sensed was coming this is why we voted
for them when it really mattered they
promised they would fight to keep this
country from falling apart
well now the crisis is here and they're
not even trying Mitch McConnell is the
most powerful Republican in the Congress
he runs the Senate that's the one
chamber Republicans still control so
what did Mitch McConnell the Senate
Majority Leader do today as American
society began to unravel Mitch McConnell
did not defend the country muster last
defend you he read talking points that
Nancy Pelosi could have written and that
benefited only her many Republican
senators did that today these people are
cowards and they are liars they pose as
your protectors they would sell you out
for the price of lunch and laugh as you
were hauled away at the very least they
could point out the endless lying all
around us there's so much of it here's
one example the mayor of Atlanta Keisha
bottoms just announced the creation of
what she called a Recovery Fund designed
to help businesses destroyed and II
quote peaceful demonstrations in Atlanta
wait a second Keisha bottoms if the
demonstrations were so peaceful why the
recovery fund you think Republicans
could at least point this out it's kind
of amusing if nothing else a recovery
fund for a peaceful demonstration but no
you can't criticize Keisha bottoms
anymore
a very serious person she may be Joe
Biden's running me respect his due and
so with no pushback the lying continues
it continues relentlessly in a torrent
from everyone in charge and no one stops
it no one even acknowledges it after a
while no citizen no one watching
believes anything the few people who
remember what America used to be like
start to think maybe they're going crazy
but they're not going crazy it's not you
it's them the country really has changed
and very fast last Friday a man in
Alabama called Michael dykes sent a text
to several of his employees dykes as the
part owner of a restaurant in Alabama
called the Parkside Cafe protests over
the death of George Floyd were
apparently hurting his business and he
was frustrated by that so in this text
Dyke criticized the protesters though he
also noted that George Floyd quote
didn't deserve to die okay then one of
dices employees promptly posted his
texts to social media and called dykes
quote hateful and evil immediately Texas
restaurant was besieged the renter
Candace Owens saw this and decided to
help Owens opened a GoFundMe page to
help the Parkside cafe compensate for
lost business within hours donors sent
in more than two hundred thousand
dollars turns out an awful lot of
Americans still believe you should be
allowed to express your opinions in
private text messages we used to take
that for granted but the tech barons who
run go fund me.com do not believe that
they don't want you to know that others
believe that if you're gonna control a
society and they want to you've got to
treat every ordinary dissident like a
dangerous revolutionary and shut them
down so that's what they did
GoFundMe immediately shut down Candace
owns his account in a statement GoFundMe
accuse Candace Owens of quote
inflammatory statements that spread hate
discrimination intolerance and
falsehoods against the black community
GoFundMe did not acknowledge that
Candace Owens is herself black but of
course it wouldn't matter anyway because
racism no longer has anything to do with
race it's a way to control disobedience
Robyn D'Angelo is one of the people who
changed how our professional class
understands the term racism D'Angelo is
the author of the barely
literate but deeply an influential book
white fragility probably heard some
sociology professor yapping on CNN and
using that term white fragility Robyn
D'Angelo did an interview with Esquire
magazine this week and she announced
that claiming you're not racist
is no longer good enough in fact it's
evidence you're a racist quote I would
urge white people to remove the phrase
I'm not racist from their vocabularies
you got that new rule they spring up out
of nowhere like mushrooms after rain but
you'd better take heed people who say
they are not racist are especially
racist got that it's the Chinese finger
trap of race guilt the harder you
struggle against the accusation the less
likely you are to get out of it the more
likely you are of being punished for it
so stop resisting sit back and take it
you have no choice racist that's what
they're telling you and a lot of people
a lot of people we used to respect are
falling for it caving to it kneeling
down before it don't be one of those
people for the sake of the country stay
strong be brave be kind be compassionate
be empathetic be loving toward your
neighbor but tell the truth we are
Americans that is our right and right
now it's our duty